Do hey,
what's going on it's Bill Birr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And
just checking in on you.
Um,
what's going on?
I am back.
The United States of America will,
you can get a gun.
You can marry a man.
And where,
uh,
I don't know.
You can,
you can go get a big goal.
You can do whatever the fuck you want here man.
This is mark.
Yeah.
Laying the frame.
Well the
land of the slurpee.
Um,
yes.
Got back yesterday.
Uh,
pretty easy flight.
You know,
I thought it was going to be a hoe.
I was going to be a rough one.
Okay.
Um,
got on with my life and my lovely daughter.
And of course my daughter started screaming bloody murder right in the beginning
cause you know,
poor thing,
it's tough for him.
Right.
And this fucking guy in front of us,
right?
We're flying business class.
Everybody's got a little bit of the hey,
you know,
we almost made it,
didn't we?
Didn't we almost have it all?
Yeah.
20 rows away from first class.
Um,
and my daughter did some high pitch scream and the guy just fucking put his hand
straight up in the year,
like really the started and then he started turning around looking at us.
So I fucking pop my head up like a goddamn something to meet his eyes.
Like,
dude,
really it's a fucking baby.
You used to be a baby,
you were on a plane and you were screaming,
you fucking asshole.
People like to have problems with babies crying.
Like,
you know,
as much of a cunt that I am,
I,
I have not had a problem with that.
It actually,
you know,
babies start crying on a plane.
It makes me,
so I set this before,
it makes me laugh because they're expressing literally what I'm thinking.
I'm ready to start crying.
I don't want to fucking do this,
you know,
how far is it
[inaudible] he can we,
can we gauge the boiling point I guess?
Right.
And nobody listens to them.
They're all standing up this Chavon jackets and the overhead compartments,
you know,
they're acting like a bunch of babies.
So anyways,
but later on the flight,
I ran into the guy up front,
uh,
when he was pouring himself a drink and I went up,
then I got to drink.
I said,
hey,
sorry about the baby crying.
And he's like,
oh,
no problem.
It's a baby boom.
Oh,
now you're a good guy.
No,
you're good.
And then for the rest of the flight,
he was,
he was cool.
He was making faces at her and shit.
You know,
I get it.
[inaudible] paid for business class,
you're about ready to take a 10 hour flight and some kids screaming bloody
murder,
you know,
really kind of ruins it.
But you know,
that's what they made earplugs for.
There was like three babies in our section and uh,
they were all putting on their own show.
But,
um,
after a while my daughter settled down,
but she scared the daylights out of a lot of people.
Um,
there's a lot of people that are just fucking selfish assholes.
Like they were born adults,
you know,
the looks that they,
they've,
they fucking give you or that we even worse,
they'll give you a kid.
It's just like,
wow,
it makes me feel better about myself,
man.
I mean,
I,
I know I'm an asshole,
but Jesus,
you know,
I,
I stopped short of mean Muggin of fucking toddler.
Ah,
no,
I've probably done that.
Not a toddler,
but when I see a fucking spoiled Brat in a store and his parents have no control
over him or her and she wants something or he wants something,
they don't get in,
they start fucking crying.
Oh Man.
If they make eye contact with me,
I'll,
I'll shoot him a look.
I admit it,
I'll do it.
You know,
I love it when the parent doesn't give,
it doesn't give the kid the fucking toy or the piece of thought,
the candy bar or whatever the fuck the kid wants.
I don't know what it is about me about it,
but it just gives me so much joy when the kid doesn't get what he wants,
you know?
And when the fucking kid gets what he wants,
I just,
I always think you fucking pussy.
I always think that,
I don't know,
it has to do with my childhood has nothing to do with children or,
or my beliefs in what we're trying to do with acis.
All right.
I'm just being honest with you fuckers.
Sorry.
I'm punishing these people with my French.
I'm trying to get my American American back together.
We speak American over here.
This is America.
We speak English.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
sought guns and roses for the first time in my life Monday night and uh,
got ridiculously hooked up.
Okay,
well I'm not going to name any names and be a Douche here,
but I just want to thank everybody who fucking was a part of hooking me up and
it was insane.
We basically sat on the side of the stage.
They gave us these inner ear monitors.
So we heard the band mix and you could hear axle making jokes in between songs
and stuff.
You know,
if he saw something of just making a random comment,
it was fucking amazing.
It was amazing.
It was like being in bill Belichick's headset and I have to tell you something.
That fucking show might've been the best concert I've ever been to.
And
I don't even,
I don't even know where to begin.
First of all,
we're in a fucking giant field right outside of Paris.
The Sun was going down.
There was all these beautiful clouds.
And my view is basically,
I see the backs of all the musicians,
which with the son fucking going down,
I got some killer.
I mean,
granted,
there's cell phone pics and everything,
but like,
first of all,
they didn't tune down any song.
They played every song in the exact same key that axle sang them in 30 fucking
years ago.
And he crushed it.
I cannot,
I can't overstate how well that guy's voice,
how well he sung I,
how great his,
we sounded like the fucking record.
And they did a three hour show,
three hour show.
I'm an old man.
Okay.
Fucking hour and a half.
I'm,
I'm usually ready to be done with it.
But this three fucking hours in,
I was actually sad when it was over.
MMM.
I,
I don't even know where to be.
It was fucking unbelievable.
Slash took this amazing solo axles.
Uh,
voice sounded incredible.
Duff's sang a song and then they had,
they threw some covers in there too.
You know,
I don't want to ruin the show for people who want to go see,
but every covered they did,
um,
was by some other B singer that sang really up in the higher register and a axle
crushed all of it.
And,
um,
it's the best of band is sound sounded since way back in the day.
I feel,
uh,
back when that classic one that they aired on MTV that I watched a thousand
fucking times,
that one where they think they were at the Roxy,
was that what it was in New York?
And um,
I remember that was on,
I had taped it on VH VHS tape on the feces.
Yeah.
And there was,
who's that fucking VJ with the long blonde hair?
And he used to wear the leather jacket.
He was from Europe or something and he was going,
uh,
this band is supposed to be the next big thing if they live long enough.
Right.
What's amazing is 30 years later,
they were all alive.
Uh,
but that was the big thing.
Um,
but anyways,
I,
it was fucking unbelievable.
That's all I'm going to say.
So if you get a chance to see them on this tour,
definitely go see them.
Like I said,
I,
I can't remember the last time they sounded this good a,
this might be the best day ever.
Sounded so,
and um,
and that's it.
And Neil was going fucking nuts during the show.
She actually,
she actually got a reaction from duff and slash sorry and a axle,
duff big smile,
laugh in watching how crazy Neil was going and then actual actually imitated the
dance that Nia was doing.
So needless to say,
she had a great fucking time and,
uh,
I'm smiling now thinking about it.
There was,
it was the perfect fucking way to end that trip.
Um,
so there you go.
and now I am back and I,
oh,
Paleo.
Oh,
freckles is jet lagged.
I did my best.
I stayed up until eight o'clock.
MMM.
You know,
last night.
But then the old Kiddo got up at three in the morning,
so I've been up since three in,
that's been a mess.
Um,
I,
uh,
oh,
by the way,
I finally broke into that fucking bottle of that chocolate salted vodka lik core
and what it was something I don't even,
what the fuck it was.
Holy Shit.
Was that a hangover?
I didn't even have that much.
I was just drinking vodka.
I was just pouring it into kind of like,
you know,
spruce it up and it tasted like ass.
But uh,
you know,
it was given to me by relatives.
So it's like I got it,
I got out of respect for them.
I got to drink some of this shit.
And the next day I woke up and I was like,
oh my God.
It wasn't even a hangover.
It was like a body pain.
And I felt like I was,
I was gonna Puke.
Like I just need to get something to eat.
So I'd go down the S,
I go down the hall,
the hall,
let's say sound rule.
Oh.
However the fuck they talk over there and I'm looking for a boulangerie that is
open.
And I find one night I just got a couple of quick thoughts,
a couple of pounds to shock a lot.
That for me,
I was getting it for everybody and uh,
but I,
I was,
I was fucked up until I got on the plane and I basically had to start drinking
again.
It was one of those sort of hangovers and uh,
oh my God,
I got so mad at my wife where they had us with a 6:20 AM pickup and my wife
goes,
man that sounds kind of early.
You know,
we not taken off til 10 20.
Right.
And she pushed the pickup back by 40 minutes,
you know,
and I love how she doesn't live in Paris and made this judgment,
see themselves early.
So for an extra 40 minutes asleep.
And um,
I'm one of those people,
if they tell you to get there two hours before,
I get that two hours before,
you know,
not a care in the fucking world.
Cause I know I don't do well with that kind of stress.
All right.
You want to stick me in a bar with a bunch of animals fucking throwing shit at
this stage.
I can handle that.
I don't know why cause I grew up with a bunch of animals but like when it comes
to that type of shit.
All right.
Were you looking at,
you know you got your wife and your kid and you're looking at a 10 hour flight.
If the fucking people who live there and know where the airport is,
say it's a t to get picked up at six 20 to get picked up at six 20
yeah.
She pushed it til seven
and everything was going great until we got there.
Those Air France,
grumpy,
grumpy fucking people working there.
We asked this lady is like no help.
Where the fuck did we stand in line?
Where do we check in?
They tell us this one line.
We stand in it and then we get elevated to the front and this fucking asshole
is,
they knew him as you.
You can do it.
I'm like [inaudible] Blah Blah Blah,
blah blah.
It's like fuck it.
Some are wearing the exact same shirt as you told us this was the right line.
And he was just like,
it was one of those guys who just takes joy in fucking ruining your day.
So then you,
then you had to go over and you had to basically check yourself in,
put the tags on your bags,
weigh your bags through the whole thing.
I was at fucking,
I was working at the airport.
Yeah,
I'll tell you,
I'm just giving yourself a tip at the end of it.
Okay.
Um,
it was ridiculous.
And then we finally get through,
um,
in all another and then she had to go,
you know,
go,
go in exchange or whatever the fuck you do there with getting your tax money
back.
She had to go fucking do that.
We stood in the wrong line and time's ticking.
Time's ticking.
And we got picked up 40 minutes later.
Then they said we should have.
And next thing you know,
we finally get through fucking security and I'm just going like,
this is so fucking stupid.
We get through security and we have to,
before we even go,
not security,
you get through customs,
we get through that.
Then we have to up,
we discover at that point we got to walk over half a terminal,
get on a fucking train before we get into this shit show security line.
And uh,
yeah,
we were going through the line.
They were already boarding the plane and I,
oh my God,
was I fucking mad?
I was just like,
it wasn't,
suppose it didn't have to be this way.
So my wife does what she always does when she's wrong is,
and she knows she's wrong.
She just immediately apologizes,
you know?
So then now what am I supposed to do?
So now.
Okay.
Oh well she said she was sorry.
She said,
you're right.
I messed up.
I'm sorry.
But yeah,
but now we're still in this situation.
I don't know.
My wife would do that in war,
you know,
if I was up on a fucking roof and she gave away our position and then all of a
sudden we're taking on fire and she just be like,
you're right.
I'm sorry.
I shouldn't have shuffled my feet like that.
What?
I said I was sorry.
You know they do that shit.
What?
I thought it was,
sorry,
I didn't know.
You know what you just like being mad,
you know,
and that they just turned the whole fucking thing around on you.
So I'm sitting there going,
they're bored in the fucking plane right now and all these fucking animals are
going to be taken our overhead compartment space and I'm just catastrophizing.
I'm fucking,
I'm like that dude and platoon,
look,
I got a bad feeling about this man.
And she is acting like,
uh,
what's his face and Kelly's heroes.
Um,
uh,
what's his,
it's a,
it's a beautiful bridge baby.
It's going to be there,
right?
She's all fucking real Donald Sutherland,
she's all fucking relaxed and I'm flipping the fuck out.
And of course we get on the plane,
you know,
we get there,
they're still boarding the plane.
We get on,
everything's fine.
The overhead compartment above our seats close.
And I'm like,
there's going to be fucking pack was shit.
And I opened up,
it was completely empty.
Everything was great.
And,
uh,
you know,
then she tries to turn it around like,
you see,
he's saying,
look,
the planes even leaving late,
like,
what's the problem?
I said,
oh,
that's,
yeah,
great ideas.
The next time we go to another country or we're not really familiar with it,
let's leave 40 minutes later and let's just count on the fact that the plane is
going to be late.
You know,
look,
I thought it was,
sorry,
I don't know what more you want from me.
What do you say to that?
It's like,
I don't want you to apologize now.
Okay.
I got to get the anger up first.
Then you apologize.
Okay.
What?
I said it was sorry.
And then it all fucking goes away.
Jesus Christ,
you know,
God forbid I do something fucking bring it up for nine years,
right?
One I said it was sorry.
Yes,
but that doesn't Blab,
blab.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm back here in the states.
I,
uh,
been up since three in the morning.
I got caught up on some of my,
um,
some of my shit that I had on the,
uh,
I still call it the Dvr or whatever the fuck you call them,
digital goddamn thing.
Now.
I watched the,
a moto GP race from Spain.
I watched Jorge Lorenzo absolutely dominate,
um,
I guess he's won two races in a row for Ducati.
Right.
Davitt CEO's so crashed out for the second time in a,
in two races,
three races I guess.
Um,
so I guess that's causing them a weird situation over there.
I don't know much about it,
but um,
I can tell you that,
uh,
I'm hoping sensitivity also seems like he's rapidly going to be out of this,
that uh,
Lorenzo keeps winning races because I would love to see him and mark has
basically go neck and neck for it the whole way,
uh,
to the end.
You know,
I hate when like the guy basically has it wrapped up in September.
Valentino Rossi made his third fucking podium in a row.
It was great cal crutch.
She'll finally get around that can took him like fucking 20 labs,
but he did it.
Um,
I enjoyed it.
You know what?
I was very tempted to try and go to that race,
but I just couldn't leave my daughter,
you know what I mean?
We had a relative over there helping us out and,
uh,
I wasn't gonna leave them,
you know,
it just felt weird leaving account country that isn't my country and leaving my
daughter.
So I said,
fuck it.
I was getting a little bit too caught up in the A,
I'm turning 50,
you only turn 50 once.
Hey,
you only turn 51 once or 49 months,
asshole,
you're a dad.
So I was like,
all right.
You know,
um,
I got hammered on the plane though.
My wife got,
she was fucking pissed at me,
um,
had a little bit,
you know,
I was thinking I was already going to be on the wagon,
but that's just that long as flight.
And,
um,
I watched that.
Oh,
I watched that fucking movie.
Dunkirk nine.
All you guys saw it in Imax.
I fucking blew it.
I was too busy and I missed it.
I watched it on the little airplane,
um,
TV,
but oh my God.
Was that movie unfucking believable?
And I knew it was going to be unbelievable because this,
this thing out here in Hollywood where when people
cannot handle that,
somebody is that much more talented than them.
They actually,
they say the same thing.
I had a buddy of mine saw that movie goes,
did you see Dunkirk yet?
And I was like,
no,
I didn't.
I've got to see it.
I heard it's unbelievable.
He goes,
yeah.
I left him.
He was like,
I don't even know what I just watched.
Like I don't even know what I just want.
I think we've donated the fuck.
It's a fucking war movie.
You asshole.
Jesus Christ.
Brush up on the history channel.
World War II,
Hitler is driving the allied forces into the ocean.
Made a huge fucking blender because he made a left turn.
He couldn't resist Paris.
He went down to Paris to go down to get a Boulogne jury to get a,
you know,
a shock,
a lot to ponder and get a little fucking frosting and is fucking Charlie Chaplin
Mustache.
He fucked up.
What he should've done was a nihilist us on that goddamn beaches.
What the fuck he should've done.
It's one of the great military blunders even I know that,
I know that cause Joe Barton,
Dick taught me that,
right?
Joe Partner gets a,
is a,
uh,
he knows all about fucking World War II.
Um,
and then I watched the movie and it was just basically a about these people,
you know,
in,
in the,
was it,
was it the French army?
The English are mainly English army.
There was some French people there to trying to get the fuck out of there.
So they didn't die.
I mean it was pretty basic what was going on there.
But the way it was shot was incredible.
And I've just noticed out here in Hollywood was when somebody is like,
like when you see a fucking movie at that Goddamn level,
I mean,
I don't,
how would you even write that script?
It was just so much action going on with no dialogue.
And it was,
it was breathtaking moving.
It was incredible.
And like,
you know,
one of the great things about knowing that you're a fucking moron as you can
enjoy somebody else's genius.
I was just sitting there going,
I could never fucking do this.
This is incredible.
And I loved it and it is buddy of mine was just going,
yeah.
I don't even know why it says watched
WWE.
I mean,
yeah,
I can see if you fucking watched you to one of those stat films and somebody do
shit on somebody shout.
I don't what the fuck I just saw,
but I have,
I'm trying to forget it.
Um,
I remember that when that Batman movie came out with that actor who played the
joker and won the Oscar.
MMM.
I'm so bad with the names and like his performance is,
the joker is,
is right up there with anything I've ever seen any actor do.
And I remember seeing this other big actor after he watched that movie saying
the exact same fucking thing.
Like,
I don't even know what I just want.
I mean,
maybe I'm not smart enough.
I don't know what that movie was supposed to meet.
I mean,
it's just,
I don't know.
I just want,
maybe you don't,
you just watch,
you just watch for look great acting performances of all time and it's making
you feel a little fucking certain way about yourself.
Yeah.
Give it up.
You asshole.
What's the matter?
Huh?
What do you play?
The green lantern and all of a sudden you fucking can't.
In a way,
this guy played the joker.
Um,
I don't even know what I just watched.
So anyways,
so I watched that movie and,
uh,
I had a script to read.
I'm a Hollywood guy who had business class.
I'm reading scripts,
right?
That's what I do.
Okay.
To see which copy am I going to play in this movie?
So anyways,
I,
uh,
I started,
you know,
I went up to the front,
I was walking my daughter up and down the aisles and then I see this,
they got a bottle of Glenn
and I was just like,
Oh shit,
there we go.
All this stupid wine and cheese in this fucking thing.
And I just poured myself a glass of wine.
And when I saw,
when I saw that,
why couldn't it done that?
I wouldn't have,
I couldn't have done that for my kid.
I don't know.
A lot of the flights are blur.
Right.
So I brought my kid back and then that's right.
I had the glass of wine
and then I saw the Glen Levitt and I was like,
oh,
that's what I want now.
What the fuck do I do with this?
So I just sucked it down
and yeah.
Then I started drinking that stuff in the second I break out like any sort of
fucking brown stuff,
like Nia eyes are on me.
Yeah.
And uh,
you know,
I had the glass of wine,
I had some shitty American food.
Then I had like three of those Glen Levitz and I got a fourth one.
Right.
It's a 10 hour flight.
I was pacing it,
I was keeping myself,
I was doing the Keith Richards thing.
He did nice.
Your key,
you get,
you get nice,
right?
And then you just kind of lead,
keep it there.
You don't get fucking messy or whatever.
But uh,
I got the fourth one,
she gave me the eyeball.
So I just set it down right.
And then I fucking took a nap for not more than 20 minutes.
And when I woke up it was gone
and I was looking at,
she fucking told that lady to take the Goddamn thinks and I had to just sit
there,
you know,
beginning my initial descent and to just sitting there stone fucking sober.
Yeah.
MMM.
I Dunno.
So anyways,
that was my last little hurrah.
So now I'm on the wagon on the wagon,
you know,
woke up this morning,
he had my steel cut oats,
my two eggs over easy banana and some strawberries.
Then I'll probably have some Ezekiel bread with some fucking almond butter.
And of course for lunch,
I've already made my keen st learn how that's how you say it was some black
beans,
maybe a little salsa.
Then I'll probably,
I don't know,
later on the afternoon have some exciting chick pea pasta that I'll have a
protein size of my hand with some sort of garden salad and then I'm just going
to crush waters and a hit the elliptical
back to that grind.
My vacation is over.
No more questions.
No more baguettes,
no more.
Glen Levitt.
All right.
To be in regular.
I'm back to fucking Clark Kent.
Uh,
it's actually good.
You know,
something was great about eating,
drinking like a pig over there is you fucking,
you know,
by the way we,
we,
we have,
you know,
I told you we had a relative on the plane too.
Okay.
So it wasn't just my wife's sitting there is her husband got shit faced.
This is my wife and another relative staring at me while I got shit faced.
I didn't get shit faced,
but I got a,
you know,
I was definitely tailgating.
How am I going to lay off?
I,
I'm going on the wagon.
They got the bottles sitting right up there.
I paid all this money for business class.
Yeah.
Um,
I always give her shit.
I have given I,
you know,
am I going to get into it?
You know,
she gives me shit.
What the fuck you gonna do?
Yeah.
You know what I should've done?
I should've walked.
What?
I'm,
I'm sorry.
You fucking,
you can't be drinking all this.
You're gonna,
you're gonna pass out and you got to think of what I said.
I was sorry.
What?
I said I was sorry.
Um,
all right.
Mandy's everybody.
Here we go.
Oh Dude.
Oh.
Don't do beyond ease me undies.
Drinking on the fucking plane.
Doo,
Doo.
Doo beyond ease my aunties,
my wife is a fucking pain.
If I pass out,
she takes my drink.
I wake up and I make a stick and then she doesn't talk to me for a couple of
movies.
And then we land at lax wearing me undies.
Me undies.
You've definitely heard me talk about me undies.
Hey,
who's kidding?
Who you've heard me sing about me on these,
you know the fun,
comfy undies that feel as good as they look to those of you who haven't tried
them yet.
Listen Up.
You can get an incredibly,
you can get incredible underwear sent to your door with me undies meaning no
more hunting around for the perfect pair at a crowded store and eventually
setting for settling for good enough.
Mian these are made with a sustainably sourced material from beechwood trees.
Still don't know how you make underwear out of trees in their soft,
some fucking Barney rubble shit.
They're naturally soft.
Fiber makes a fabric that won't sag down or write up.
Okay?
That's what it is.
It's flying.
The underwear flies in formation with the and nuts.
Trust me,
once you,
you put on a pair of,
you're going to get it.
Me undies is so sure you'll love the first pair that if you're not happy,
they'll do whatever they can to get you into the right pair.
And if they can't,
just realize,
you know,
some people's balls hang one hangs lower than the other.
Maybe that's what the problem is.
You know,
get somebody on there.
Can you describe your,
uh,
your genitalia?
Yeah.
Um,
and if they can't keep them and they'll refund you.
So it really is risk free to try the best underwear ever.
Okay.
Now are you looking in a mirror?
He makes sure it your left,
you're saying your left testicle hangs lower.
All right.
Is there anybody there that can confirm this can look at you just in case cause
we know Bob would just be packed.
People when they look in a mirror they get confused about which uh,
Baldor looking at all right.
We're just trying to make sure that this is a win win for you.
And if you're already part of Mandy's family,
tell your friends about it through their referral program.
They'll get a discount and you get a store credit.
It's a win win.
Still not sure.
Well,
Mandy's has a deal from my listeners.
First Time purchasers get 15% off their first pair of me undies and free
shipping.
That's 15% off plus free shipping and a guarantee that you and your Mondays
we'll be happy
together.
I cared.
See me having my balls or no one else.
Um,
get your butt over to [inaudible] dot com and treat yourself to get your 15% off
your first pair of free shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to me
undies.com/bird that's me,
undies.com/bird oh look who's,
oh look who's back.
I love these guys.
I you want,
here's a product that I love.
I use and I back butchers box.
Not to be confused with nature's box.
Mother Nature's
butchers box.
Put your box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage bread,
pork heritage bread breed,
B,
r e e d heritage breed pork.
Sorry,
directly to Jordan.
I'm going to tell you that is the best God damn pork chop I've ever effing had.
Okay.
It's,
it's fucking delicious.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely before we kill them and free of antibiotics and
hormones.
Each box comes with the at least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
You can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork.
The mixed box.
The custom box with such,
you choose your own cuts.
A Guy,
I cannot tell you how many.
Oh my God,
that pork chop,
that piece of pork.
Oh my God,
it was fucking delicious.
How about butcher?
How Butcher box works?
First we feed the animals that we let them outside.
Then we shoot him in the head.
Choose from curated boxes including a mix of high quality beef,
chicken or pork,
or customize your own box.
Meat is frozen at the peak of freshness in individual vacuum packed
biodegradable packaging.
All meet is delivered right to your doorstep for free.
This is 100% true.
This is exactly what my experience.
Then you throw it in your freezer.
You thought what you want,
you take out your fucking skillet,
right?
You sear it on both sides.
You finish it in the oven.
Take it back out,
give it a little butter bath with some fucking garlic.
Oh,
is in a tasty portrait.
Put your box believes in a healthier food system where everyone has access to
meet the way nature intended.
Uh,
free of antibiotics.
He spelled meet,
rung,
he spelt it.
M Oh no,
you spelled it right.
M.
E.
T.
No,
it's met.
Meet is,
I'm going to meet you over there,
uh,
and hormones and humanely raised.
Can I please host the fucking national spelling bee?
Uh,
meat can use it in a sentence.
A,
a fucking meet me over there.
Okay.
Our,
um,
Cook with the peace of mind,
knowing,
feeding your family healthy.
Hi.
Uh,
just got cut off some.
I'm gonna cut off the healthy high.
Something other convenience.
Think of what's your boxes,
your neighborhood butcher with their quality beef,
chicken and pork delivered right to your door.
Choose your delivery frequency with customs is audible.
Subscription recipes are available on butcher box.
Website and videos are available to follow us.
Perfect.
So you get this great cut of meat.
You don't want to fuck it up.
They'll show you how to season it and then pretty soon they'll have videos.
They're doing everything but coming over and cook in the sink for you.
If you have received a butcher box,
part of the re includes your person.
Include your personal experience.
Hey,
this is as personal as it gets for $20 off your first box and an order of free
bacon,
go to butcher box.com
repeat entire call to action,
but why don't you write it again?
The $20 off your first box in and in order of Free Bacon,
go to butcher box.com I think this will be slash burr and enter in Promo.
I says unique URL and enter Promo code.
Who gives a fuck?
It's delicious.
Just go there in order to promote a butcher box.com.
All right.
He likes everybody.
Alex,
there's nobody on the planet like you,
and that may or may not be a compliment depending on how you are.
So why would you buy a mattress built for everyone else
working with the world's leading sleep experts?
That's a,
that's a,
that's a great fucking job.
Go back to your high school reunion.
Whatever happened to you.
Well,
I'm a sleep expert.
Helix sleep developed a mattress that customized to you.
I can tell by your [inaudible] you're not.
You don't have the right mattress.
That's cust.
Okay.
Helix helicase sleep developed a mattress that customized to your specific
height,
weight,
sleep,
and sleep preferences.
So you can have the best sleep of your life at an unbeatable price.
They must be amazing,
Huh?
They have one that knows,
you know which way.
If you lean it on your side,
if you junk does or does not touch the mattress so he can kind of,
you know,
cradle it.
Here's how it works.
Go to helix,
sleep.com fill out their two minutes sleep quiz,
and they'll design your custom mattress.
They can even customize each side for you and your partner.
A very progressive
did not say spouse to their say partner.
Right?
Although gay people get married in most states,
right?
Maybe you call your dog partner,
which you guys do behind closed doors is your own damn business in 2018 he looks
sleep.
Could you please not bring up beastiality during the read?
Other than that.
We loved it in 2018 he looks sleep has taken custom,
customized sleep to the next level.
What the hell?
It's pillow pillow.
The all new pillows are fully adjustable so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of sleep position of body type,
fully adjustable.
I'm just picturing somebody punching it like you do with anything else.
There's be something more to it than that.
Heloc sleep has thousands of five star reviews.
Plus you get a hundred nights to try them out.
Grouse,
go to healing.
sleep.com/bar right now and you get up to $125 on your mattress order.
That's helix sleep.com/burr $425 off your mattress.
Order helic sleep.com/ [inaudible] berm.
All right,
that wasn't bad for being jetlag jet leg.
Billy,
what's the deal?
Um,
anyways.
All right,
so I'm back on it back on and I did 50 minutes a yoga this morning at like four
in the morning
because my,
uh,
my lower body is not feeling good these days,
riding on all these goddamn airplane.
So I'm gonna go get a fucking massage today.
Have somebody jam they fucking elbow into my hammies,
try to free him up again.
You know,
calves are all fucked up.
Um,
I got to Smith Sues Right.
Fucking kills me in a good way.
Right.
I swear to God,
like my calves when she was pushing down on them,
no one's ever like,
I didn't know that.
You know,
back in the day if anybody ever gave me a massage,
be even any part of your body is sensitive like yeah,
my calves,
my calves.
So they would stay away from it.
I didn't realize that that meant they were all glued up and shit.
So this person's been working on it and I'm literally coming up off the table at
barely any pressure from the elbow.
Okay.
And she goes to see what's,
what does it feel like?
Like what,
what type of paint I go,
it feels like there's a ball of Hornets
in my fucking cabs.
Um,
but I've just been too busy to have her finish and get it all back to the way it
used to be because,
oh,
cause whatever cause of my fucking life.
But I have to tell you man,
um,
being a 50 year old man now,
if you,
if you could find a good misuse,
uh,
the,
the quality of life that you're going to have,
you know,
if you stretch,
if you eat right,
if you don't drink Glenn all the way back from Paris,
which I did,
I'm exaggerating for comedy effect.
All right.
Um,
like I was having this problem where I would be,
I would lay down and I would watch TV for like sometimes as little as like 20
minutes.
And when I would go to stand up,
like I had to stretch.
That's like how fucked up my calves were.
And I'm like,
I felt like my Achilles tendon was going to snap.
Like something was going to snap.
So I've just been having this woman beat the shit out of my legs and a co that's
,
you know,
what I found out,
it was back when I had that psychotic nerve issue.
Um,
and I felt a little twinge of that starting to come back,
just that little bit of tightness.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
she's going to turn me into hamburger tomorrow hopefully.
Um,
and that's it.
All right.
That's the podcast here for this week.
So great to be back here.
Thanks again to everybody and Dublin,
Ireland,
Ireland that came out to the show.
Thanks to everybody in London,
England.
Uh,
you know,
thanks everybody in Paris,
France for putting up with my French.
Um,
thank you to guns and roses for putting on the best concert I've ever seen.
And uh,
that's it.
I guess I'm just really good,
thankful.
Um,
enjoy the music and you can listen to another half hour of Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Greatest hits from
the Thursday earlier this year or years ago.
I have no idea.
All right.
Uh,
that's it.
Have a great weekend.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
like a,
and then we started watching this
series on Netflix.
It was something about these shifts.
It was all these,
these French cooks and a,
it was great to hear the French language cause I kind of stopped it once again,
I was picking up,
you know,
little phrases here or there that made me feel good in these fucking,
these chefs were incredible watch like two or three episodes of it.
Of course.
I don't know what the name of it is
[inaudible] but it made me want to live in Paris for like fucking three months,
four months,
five,
whatever it would take just to get kind of passable and take a pastry making
class.
I know that sounds like the stupidest thing ever,
but this fucking guy,
he takes like an apple and he was going like this guy was an artist.
He was just sitting there going like,
you know,
I'm so of making all these
fucking thing.
I had to come up with some new
thing to do with an apple and he fucking just imagine if he just kept peeling a
thing.
Right.
If you just peeling the skin off,
but you just kept going all the way down into the core.
He did that and it was all one piece you did with some hand crank thing and he
said,
I wanted to make a rose out of out of an apple.
And he somehow did it and turned it into a dessert.
[inaudible] visual Monday.
Who?
[inaudible] [inaudible] to [inaudible] in Nash.
Okay.
Second male view
on [inaudible] this sauce you believe man did I beat
[inaudible]
fucking chop to duck in a,
in a chicken in half.
And he sewed them together,
which was very naziesque slash American horror story that kind of creeped me
out.
Sassy colon food,
the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and then of course they had to show how they fucking,
they were cooking lobsters,
live lobsters over an open flame.
Can I kiss you guys a question?
What?
What are the lobster ever do to us?
Every other animal has the decency of being dead before we fucking,
at least in this country.
I know other countries,
they've got fucking mad maggots running around their apple jacks for extra
protein.
You know,
that's like us putting white powder into our shakes.
They put like fucking bugs and stuff,
you know what I mean?
Puts a little spring in your step.
A little twinkle in your eyes.
So anyways,
I'm watching this fucking lunatic and um,
for the life of me,
I don't know why they just can't.
At least just,
can you just fucking,
I don't know.
Can they make it like a little lobster hammer and just fucking knock,
knock it out.
At least does it have to be squirming on the flame and you have to keep telling
me that it doesn't feel pain.
It doesn't have a central nervous system.
Whatever the fuck they try to say.
It's just like,
like what?
It's like an Amoeba.
It isn't.
Okay.
The fucking things got eyeballs and shit.
It's walking around.
It's got its little tentacles.
What did we call it?
Those,
those big fucking thing's coming out.
It can see it breathes.
You gotta have paid.
That's part of survival,
right?
Wish it was a way to shut it off.
I'm Jesus.
I'm all over the map.
I was talking about La fucking not Lsu.
I was talking about Alabama,
USC.
Now where the hell am I?
So anyways,
the guy got sick of talking about a week after a while,
he just got sick of the blood of all the animals.
Excuse yourself,
at a seat.
[inaudible]
city Tammany
eight.
I pushed it back to you.
[inaudible]
and he got three stars over and,
and,
and um,
in France in three stars is the highest you can get,
which is so fucking Parisian.
You know what I mean?
Is so fucking understated and classy.
I hate to say it is American,
but they really are.
They really earned their snooty fucking behavior over there.
The people that style,
they closed it,
they crush it.
You know,
Mister t would got himself a gold chain and it was this like,
you know what,
one isn't enough.
Let me get fucking 9,000 of them and hanger.
They're the exact opposite of that.
They got like all mood muted colors and then Bam,
a sick as pair of shoes or a hat or the ladies with their bags,
just fucking class.
It's not like,
you know,
it's not like us loud Americans,
but it's good to be loud sometimes.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built bar and it is the Monday morning
podcast for Monday,
June 21st,
2010.
How the hell are you?
God dammit.
You like that.
That's my like,
come on,
let's fucking do this.
You know,
like he gave up on your dreams and you picked an easy fucking drone route.
Got a job at a corporation and I'm the first guy that,
you know,
you're going to meet and I'm trying to get everybody all on the same team.
Come on everybody.
You know,
let's go look at some spreadsheets.
Why can't I fucking hear myself?
I'm screaming right now and I'm not hearing the volume in my headphones.
These headphones getting old.
Okay.
You don't,
are they made in America?
Is anything made in America anymore?
I have no fucking idea.
But anyways,
I'm actually taping this on.
Um,
what is it?
Sunday,
June 20th.
So it is father's day.
So happy belated father's day,
everybody,
you know,
I hate that word.
Belated happy birthday.
Happy Birthday.
Happy Father's Day to all the fathers out there who stuck around,
you know,
happy father's Day.
You know,
even in the father's,
you know,
you're married some Twat,
you realize you didn't,
you didn't love her anymore and you know,
she fucking took off and started banging on the fucking dude down the street.
So you flipped out,
you threw some furniture,
and now you're considered danger to her and your children.
You can't really see them today.
Happy Father's Day to you too.
But no happy father's day to somebody who just knock somebody up and never hung
around.
You're not a father.
You're a guy with a dick who shot a load into a vagina and you fucking left.
You left,
you're riding the bench.
You're not in the game.
So a
happy father's Day fuckers.
Um,
what'd you get?
You get some ship gifts like all guys get,
you know what a women,
what do women get on Mother's Day?
What do they get high?
They get fucking pancakes.
You know,
what does a guy get a new breathable shirt for when he goes out and most of the
lawn that day?
Is that what you get?
Some fucking
what do you get a new driver?
I'm a dad.
Get some fucking tool for the garage.
Something to help you fix the fucking place up.
You know,
I got a lot of balls that actually got my girl,
uh,
a gift certificate,
gift certificate to some cooking classes,
uh,
one year for her birthday,
you know,
and that was one of those gifts.
As I gave it to her,
I was like,
this is,
she's either going to love this or I'm really going to piss her off because it
is a very nice gift.
But there's also an element of a,
why don't you learn how to cook,
bitch?
Um,
but it wasn't that,
you know,
this is actually a gourmets,
whatever I'm going to fucking make out in the deal.
So douchey gift.
And I gave it to her,
looked her right in the eye and said,
here you go.
Here's my gift to you that will make my life better because you become more of
the person that I want you to be.
Did that make sense?
Anyways,
I had an awesome weekend working down the,
uh,
the Improv in Hollywood,
sold out three shows.
And let me tell you something.
It's a small club,
but it's still,
I was very impressed that everybody came up because that's a hard ticket to sell
here in Hollywood.
You know,
when Leonardo Dicaprio's also having a pool party the same fucking night,
do you think anybody wants to come down to the Melrose Improv?
They don't
win.
The fucking
corona girls are showing their twats up on Fairfax in Sunday,
sunset,
Sunday sunset or whatever that all that Hollywood shit's going on.
So the fact that everybody came down to see me was really awesome.
And even though the Improv spelled my name incorrectly on the Marquee,
B U R R r
Bill Burr,
we'll be performing tonight.
Uh,
I had a great time working out my new hour,
some hiccups here or there and,
uh,
all the shows went great except for the late show Saturday night.
Uh,
it was kind hit a weird show where there was this woman talking.
This lady was rubbing it,
running her fucking mouth as they do.
You know,
they can't help it.
They're emotional.
Do you know women say like twice as many words a day as men.
What you fucking Dick?
I didn't notice.
Do you think none of us didn't notice?
You know,
just cause you're saying twice as many words during the course of the day
doesn't mean you're really saying anything.
You know,
you ever been hanging out with people and everybody's running their mouths about
how to solve a fucking problem and this,
that quiet person in the corner and like when three words,
they sum up what the fuck we should be doing this because you're running your
Yap doesn't mean you say anything.
Just cause all you broads out there have so fucking afraid of silence,
you know,
because your clock is ticking or whatever the hell's going on with your fucking
bodies.
Jesus Christ.
Do you fucking cycles.
Sorry,
I don't know why I'm being so ignorant right now.
I respect women,
you know,
and their wounds and their ability though to a,
take a load,
you know,
and then fucking walk around as it gets created with no effort on their part
whatsoever.
You know,
me shooting the load really doesn't take any fucking effort,
you know,
a couple of strokes back and forth.
I'm a good two minute man.
Does that feel good?
Ah,
that's it.
That's my game.
Deal with it.
You've got to focus.
This is really disgusting.
I usually don't do sex jokes like that.
A lot of bodily fluids so far.
But once again,
I'm doing,
I'm doing this,
uh,
this part.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Stay on target.
Stay on fucking stay on.
Stay focused here.
I was going to talk about that.
Um,
the,
uh,
the third show.
So I'm doing my show and you know,
it's going great and I hear this yammering in the law,
you know,
out of my left ear and I look over and Lo and behold,
it's some woman talking to this other woman.
And I said,
hey,
hey.
And she was so involved in a conversation that I,
she couldn't even hear me,
you know,
standing 10 feet away with a spotlight and a microphone.
She couldn't hear me say alone.
Hey Man,
man,
yes you ma'am please.
Huh?
Can you listen to me?
Thank you.
So she shuts up.
I do my shit.
And then like five minutes later,
I dunno what she did,
she started heckling me.
And by the way,
when the crowd gives me shit that's heckling when I give them shit,
I'm not heckling,
there's like four people came up to me this weekend.
I like how you heckled that woman in the audience.
Heckling is what an audience member does.
We'll have the definition up on the [inaudible] podcast.com where you can get
all your little tidbits,
your little fucking,
uh,
Bacon bits off of the podcast if you new to the podcast needed.
And if I,
if I throw out references that you don't understand and when I recommend youtube
videos and you're like,
Jesus Christ,
do I have to go to youtube and I have to look up all these videos?
Wouldn't it be great if there was a webpage that just had all the videos that he
recommended and pictures of the references that he made in links to shit that he
talked to,
rather than me having to make a list on posted after posted in my fucking
cubicle.
Well we got that for
you@wwwdotthemmpodcast.com you go there,
you'll see all of this shit.
And I described that so,
well I totally forgot what the fuck I was talking about.
Oh,
that's right.
A definition of a heckling.
Heckling is what somebody in the crowd does to a performer.
All right?
There's all different kinds of heckles.
There's,
you could be heckling even saying something nice fucking up my rhythm.
I was walking down the street the other day.
Oh,
I've done that.
I love streets.
You know,
that's a form of heckling.
It's one of the hardest hecklers to deal with.
All right.
But when I'm trashing someone in the crowd,
I'm just doing crowd work,
doing crowd work.
If they didn't say anything,
hey,
where are you from?
That's playing with the crowd.
But it is not heckling.
So stop coming up to me at the end of my show is going,
I like the way you heckled that guy in the crowd.
How exactly did I do that?
Did I sit in the audience and then put the audience on fucking stage.
All right bill.
We got it.
You made your point.
Okay.
You're right.
Sorry.
So anyways,
um,
anyway,
she like after I said,
ma'am,
hello,
I'm trying to do my act here.
I got back into my act like five,
six,
five or six seconds later,
um,
she yelled something at me,
something,
some sort of non sequitur.
Oh,
I said,
I gotta take my dog to the dog whisperer.
And she goes,
should I go?
What?
She goes,
you said dog.
Whisperers I went,
Shit.
And it was just dead silence.
I was like,
what?
And I was literally looking at her like,
does this,
does this person,
is this person mentally challenged before I go with,
cause you've got to make that assessment because you don't want to do that,
you know?
So,
uh,
I dunno,
you know,
what end up happening was she had a major issue with the fact that I called her
ma'am.
You know,
which brings up a very interesting point in your life is where a woman goes from
young lady to a man.
And when a guy goes from young man to assert,
you guys all remember the first time somebody called you sir or Ma'am and you
were like,
Jesus Christ,
I'm fucking old.
But after a while you deal with it and you'll start,
you forget.
You forget that people are even saying that.
Especially cause most of the time nowadays when someone's calling you sir or
ma'am,
it's some Douche on the phone that you're trying to get to help you,
but they can help you.
Yes.
I'm sorry sir.
I understand sir.
Yes.
Well there's nothing I can do sir.
Ma'Am,
ma'am,
I'm trying to help you but I'm sorry.
I don't know why they transferred you to me ma'am.
And you're just more pissed off about the subject.
But there is that moment.
The first time somebody calls you sir,
or ma'am,
which I get,
but if you saw this lady,
she was at least fucking eight years into being a man,
you know.
In fact,
a good friend of mine watching the show,
Neil Brennan was standing back at the back of the room and after the show he
goes,
she was so a ma'am,
you know,
and she was,
she looked like that girl who played Nelly on little house in the prairie.
Remember that?
The 13 year old cunt with a fucking,
uh,
Cindy Brady haircut it 15 and she was just a cunt,
the entire fucking series.
We'll just imagine if that cunt was now fucking like,
I mean,
this girl was like 36,
37,
easy,
easy.
You know,
she already had,
you know,
when you start getting the job roles is that whatever that you're,
it's not your chin,
they call it a double chin,
but it's really,
it's the flesh between Your Chin and your Adam's apple.
It starts to sag a little bit.
Gravity has been pulling on it.
She had that and about two tons of fucking blush on her face.
And,
um,
oh,
she was such a,
you know,
she's Douche bag of the week.
She was really douche bag of the week.
She just kept running her mouth.
And um,
I know I've got a thing.
Why'd I tried?
This is hilarious after everything I just said this week on the podcast so far,
I try not to attack a,
there's a few things I don't do.
I don't,
I don't make fun of mentally challenged people.
You know,
I did that a couple times in my career,
did not go well and I felt like an asshole afterwards.
So I cut that out and uh,
you know,
I don't go after women's looks.
That's usually,
that's usually a last resort because a,
I don't know,
it just,
you know,
this,
believe it or not,
there's certain things that are too mean,
but on the podcast evidentaly I can fucking go off on women.
Is that what it is,
Bill?
I'm trying to think of all the shit I said in the last 12 minutes.
I'm sure I'm being totally fucking hypocritical right now,
but whatever,
it's my podcast.
Oh,
speaking of that shit,
my girl was watching one of these dumb ass fucking shows this week.
You know,
those shows the,
uh,
the real fucking horny housewives of fucking Toledo,
you know,
they've got their faces fucking Yank back and that desperately trying not to be
their age for whatever fucking reason,
for whatever reason.
You know,
why can't they have them looking like moms,
you know,
so you can actually relax and enjoy the show and look at someone who's 42,
who looks 42 and they're happy and they're in some sort of a stable
relationship.
Rather than show in these cunts,
go into these fucking art shows and sipping wine.
Is that doing squats up against a fucking refrigerator desperately trying to
hold onto their youth.
It's fucking over lady.
You got like three kids relax.
I'm not saying become disgustingly out of shape,
so you have heart disease,
but to sit there and go to the mall and at your age and by the latest,
the same fucking genes that the kids are wearing,
you look ridiculous.
You look ridiculous.
Whole fucking,
uh,
what is it,
cougars?
Is that what they call them?
You know,
it's sad the same way.
It's sad when you see a fucking older guy doing the same shit hitting on fucking
younger girls.
It's sad.
But of course when women do it,
it's empowering.
Anything they do,
it's fucking empowering the exact same shit.
We do all this,
you know,
we're sad.
We're sitting at Hooters and we're fucking pathetic and everybody goes off
saying,
I'll,
you know,
fucking said our lifestyle.
A woman does it.
They can make a goddamn series of it.
Why can't you know that Cougar town,
when they make dirty old man town
and they do it in the fucking guy would be,
would be considered a fucking creep and a woman does it for,
I guess it's considered an accomplishment because guys are so visually
motivated.
They're like,
wow,
an old bag.
Like you can still get a young guy guys,
good for you.
Good for you.
You're with your lizard tits.
I'm see.
There you go.
Being hypocritical again.
Sorry.
So,
uh,
anyway,
she's Douche bag of the weekend.
I actually was one of the few times I ever had somebody kicked out,
you know,
the bouncer came over at the first,
I was like,
no,
no.
I'm kind of enjoying this.
I like a little bit of back and forth and um,
I thought we were going to get to some sort of resolution,
but like by the fifth time I went back and forth with her,
the whole crowd,
they weren't laughing.
They just went,
Oh God,
shut up.
So then that becomes like,
okay,
now people aren't getting their money's worth and that's gonna Affect my
fucking,
you know,
career.
So you got to go.
So they kicked her out,
they kicked her out and I'm sure she drove home feeling like it was some sort of
victory.
See that he kicked me out because he couldn't deal with me.
Ha Ha.
That's her playing with their chins.
Um,
it's like,
no,
if he just,
you just sort of a content,
everyone wants you to leave.
You don't want to say cut too much more on this podcast.
I've noticed that and all of a sudden I've made up for it in the last three
minutes,
made up for the last 26 podcasts.
Um,
so anyways,
what else?
Oh Jesus.
Let's delve into it.
The Boston Celtics lost to the Los Angeles Lakers in seven games.
Man,
it was fucking brutal.
Uh,
one of the ugliest seven,
uh,
game sevens I've ever seen.
And
um,
if you really look at the series in general,
it was a pretty ugly scene,
the whole fucking series.
And uh,
I don't remember last week when I was like,
you know,
we're in a good spot,
but I can't,
I can't get any read on this series because it was so fucked.
So the only pattern I could see was the Celtics were old.
So when they flew out for game one,
they were tired and they got the shit kicked out of them.
They get a good night's sleep.
They win game two.
All right.
They fly back to Boston,
they're tired again.
They lose the game,
get a good night's sleep to come back.
They wouldn't games four and five fly out to la.
They're tired again.
They get their fucking asses kicked,
they get a good night's sleep.
I'm thinking they're going to win game seven.
And uh,
they did not,
unfortunately.
I just think,
you know,
Kendrick Perkins that was just too much for us to lose,
took on too much water and uh,
the Lakers were just younger,
more talented and uh,
you know,
when they get 13 of the first 15 fucking rebounds,
I don't know how we were still winning that game,
but um,
you know,
it was definitely brutal.
It was fucking brutal and as much respect as I had for Pau Gasol,
I started the fucking hate him again.
You know,
the fucking asshole man.
It's like he,
before he even drives to the hoop,
he already has a look on his face.
Like he's getting fouled and the way he fucking flops around.
I was joking around this weekend,
you have a drive by some shitty car wash and they have like that celery stock
fucking looking thing.
It looks like a guy and they,
and they shoot air up into it and it's fucking arms flap all around.
That's what the power Gasol looks like going into the fucking hoop.
And I'm,
and I got to tell you something,
you know,
I'm not taking anything away from the Lakers because I just think out of all
four major sports,
the officiating in the NBA is absolutely fucking horrific.
To the point I've been saying this forever,
that the refs literally dictate the pace of the game.
You know,
it used to be the point guards when they wanted to speed it up and slow it down
or whatever.
Guys on either team would do things.
The point guards,
they would,
they'd pick it up or slow it down.
Now it's still refs.
Now it's the Reps.
Oh,
let's let him play first half.
We fucking tackle cobia one play.
They let it go.
I'm like,
that's exactly how you should be calling this game.
It's game seven.
Let them go.
And then when it really fucking counted in the fourth quarter,
they would just run it down the core with their whistles in their miles.
And I don't want to be country here,
but what the fuck?
You know what I mean?
None of the Lakers were falling people and then all that bullshit with the
relationship.
I mean,
I get it.
Kobi drives into Rashid,
Kobe's the face of the league.
I get it.
He's going to get the call the same way Tom Brady gets the calls the same way
Jordan gets the calls.
I get that and I,
you know,
but if Rasheed Wallace is standing sideways with his arms down by his side and
he's not moving,
it fucking jumps into him.
I get the no call because it's Colby and he gets to superstar rule.
But if you're going to call a foul that's fucking offensive to put Coby on the
line on a horse shit call like that during game seven,
man.
That's what the fucking reps,
and I'm not shitting on the Lakers,
I'm not taking this away from him,
but I fucking hate the NBA reps get out of the Goddamn way.
Let him play.
So fucking annoying.
Go all the way to game seven and it's decided on penalty shots.
It's like that fucking World Cup soccer
such as,
you know,
I've,
I've gone back to saying it's a stupid fucking sport.
Can somebody explain to me the offsides and soccer why you're not allowed to get
behind the defender.
That defeats the fucking purpose of every sport.
I understand.
Like,
you know,
one guy just can't run down the field to be hanging down by the other guys net.
I get that.
But the way the dif,
the defense is the off sideline that basically moves down the field and you'll
see an offensive players start to run by it and the defensive player just stops
running.
So then what the offensive player has to stop running because the defensive guys
out of fucking position,
it's,
it's no,
no wonder you have one to nothing games,
Neil Neal.
What a contest.
Jesus Christ in those fucking idiots down there blowing those,
those horns that sound like mosquitoes for the whole fucking game.
I haven't won.
I'm going to get involved in the second real reason why I haven't gotten into it
was because I was watching,
I was watching the Lakers,
a Celtics and uh,
you know,
whatever.
Congratulations.
Lakers fans,
you know,
whatever.
God bless you.
I'm past the hate.
I don't do that shit.
But,
uh,
you know,
and that was a hell of a celebration too,
that you guys had,
you know,
that was awesome.
You win a championship.
Yeah.
Let's go tip over a car.
Ah,
take that you fucking automobile talking shit.
The whole series.
Now what do you got to say?
Huh?
Store front window.
I didn't think so.
That was what really surprised me is the classless level of fans out here.
I don't get it.
It's so bizarre.
We have the,
uh,
the court side Laker fans,
which is the highest douchebag factor,
even more so than the Boston fans.
The few who dress up like leprechauns that make me want to hang myself.
Um,
that douchebag factor,
everybody went there.
Ashton Kutcher,
bing Crosby hats on
and their rockstar jewelry.
Did you see that one game?
I think it was game seven when they won and they won.
They were cutting to a,
the three guys announcing the game Van Gundy,
uh,
Mark Jackson and a fucking,
whatever the other guy's name was.
And uh,
that fucking like 48 year old guy holding his gold jewelry.
I think he had like a Laker pendant.
You know,
like he's 21,
the whole fucking thing was ridiculous,
but I don't get how you have like around the court,
you've got these fucking fans.
They show up like halfway through the second quarter that are on their cell
phones and shit.
Text messaging.
Like,
did you see Courtney Cox,
Cox sitting us speaking a Cougar town sitting court side.
She looked like she was waiting to get her fucking nails done.
No emotion.
Just sitting there in our leather pants.
So it really looks like there's not a lot of passion or at least on the side
core behind under the hoop you can start to get real Laker fans.
But then like up top,
like I don't understand those people.
Those people take it.
I think they're making up for the,
uh,
who gives a fuck attitude of like the cast of whatever new hits.
Sit-Com got the fucking court side seats and they start tipping over shit.
I Dunno.
It's like,
what are you Canadian fans?
I gotta be honest with you for as much shit as they give Philly.
Philadelphia fans,
you know they,
they throw,
they throw a,
they threw snowballs at Santa Claus.
Oh yeah.
Do they tip over a police car and light it on fire?
Did you see that shit after they won?
That's what kills me.
They won and it looked like fucking Tiananmen Square.
The only time I ever saw that in Boston was after we broke an 86 year curse and
you knew some shit was going to go down.
You knew it that much fucking rage.
But they want it two years ago.
You see that?
I'm justifying when we act like Douche bags,
but when we win a basketball championship,
we don't freak out.
I don't know.
I gotta be honest with you.
Sports out here,
it's,
it's not fun.
Like back east,
there's a lot of shit talk and there's a lot of ball breaking and believe me,
I took a ton of Shit in New York,
but there was an element of fun with the misery.
But out here it's,
it's not fun.
You go to games out here,
you know,
you go to a game in Philly like,
okay,
someone's going to dump a beer on me,
maybe I'll get puked on,
you know,
you come out here,
you're like,
you know,
I think I'm going to get stabbed.
And I had that experience at a fucking charger game at a,
at an angel's game.
And uh,
actually not at a Lakers game,
just at a charge.
Is Lakers,
Anna Dodger's game.
And um,
you know,
I dunno.
I mean granted,
the,
the common denominator in all three of those is the fact that I went to a game,
but whatever I talk,
shit,
I get a little drunk,
I talk shit,
Talk Shit back to me,
you know,
so now what we're supposed to be delivered,
but you know,
to take it to the level that you're going to fucking stab me.
I don't fucking know,
Eh.
Right.
Let's get on.
And then I'd like an asshole.
I sat there and I watched the,
the post game,
the Lakers post game where they had Michael Cooper and some chick from the WWE
NBA,
you know,
you would think with all the Great Lakers that they could get another fucking
Laker.
Great.
They wanted a former player,
but I get it that trying to hype the fucking Wnb a so this fucking twat comes on
there,
right?
And starts the WNB.
A chicken starts trashing Kevin Garnett,
which is such the classic country thing to do where it's like,
first of all,
sweetheart,
you are on the edge of your seat and didn't know the Lakers were gonna win this
series until there was about 41 seconds left and now that you,
one you're going to act like it was in the bag and she's,
she was trash.
And Kevin Garnett,
right?
Kicking him when he's down,
the guy comes off major knee surgery,
his fucking arm was jacked up.
He never bitched,
never made any excuses,
never responded.
When Pau Gasol said he's lost a step,
never said shit and this shit goes,
the big ticket should have called them the big coupon
enough,
Katie.
Well,
I want a fucking classic.
It's just unbelievable.
So out of a fellow athlete,
you're going to do that.
I could see,
you know,
even,
uh,
a former NBA player maybe,
but a WNB a play.
I was joking about that shit all this weekend.
WNB a really,
you're going to talk shit about Kevin Garnett.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
What do you get your Wnb a,
you've got to have a fucking bake sale at half time.
See a check doesn't bounce.
I Dunno.
It was really,
I was really surprised that the classless level of behavior with the fucking
people trash and debt,
the downtown,
her talk and Shit and even Michael Cooper still being like a cunt where it's
like you won,
you don't have to think is it's really easy to be classy when you win.
And uh,
they couldn't even do that.
So I kind of lost an element of respect for the Lakers,
but I'm sure they don't give a fuck.
But,
uh,
um,
I don't know.
But I'm actually proud of the Celtics because if you looked at it on paper,
we should have got absolutely destroyed.
And somehow it went seven games and I dunno,
I don't know how the fuck we ended up losing it.
In the end.
We will actually,
we know what the lake has made a great adjustment.
MMM.
What's his face,
Ron?
Our tests when he started shutting down Paul Pierce and no one else could step
it up.
I thought that they made a great adjustment and uh,
we couldn't overcome it and then they went on like that fucking 13 zero run.
And uh,
that was it.
And what really kills me as a Celtic fan is that Coby shit,
the bed shit,
the bed,
like we're talking about a John Starks level in a game seven.
Okay.
And once again,
I was going to feel vindicated the same way I did with Peyton manning when
everyone was saying you're arguably looking at the greatest quarterback of all
time.
Same thing with Coby Bryan.
All right.
He's fucking guys who keep trying to say,
compare him to Michael Jordan.
He's not.
Okay.
Who's the second guy to go to the moon.
Does anybody?
Exactly.
Cause no one gives a fuck.
Did a second guy go to the moon?
Did we ever go to the moon?
That was a bad example.
You know,
who's the second guy who made a light bulb work?
Nobody knows.
Just be you doing something that's already fucking been done by somebody great
does not make you on the same level of great.
It's when you do something great that's never been done before.
That's what separates you.
Okay?
I'm not going to go into this fucking rant again,
but Coby Bryan Shit,
the fucking bed and that fucking Mark Jackson,
Jesus Christ,
he's got a poster,
a Colby over his bed.
At one point,
Colby was too for 19 in game seven two four 19 it's somebody for fucking van
Gundy brings it up when you get fucking Jackson's like,
yeah,
but he's got 12 big rebounds,
but guy,
he runs down the court.
I love the shape of his calves.
He shit the bed Pagasa all kind of shit.
The bed to my son's missing all those foul shots,
that bearded ballerina with his fucking fundamental European game.
You don't miss those,
but it was game seven.
He bitched up a little bit,
you know,
but you need a little bit of luck to win it.
And I think a Rashid go into same way the Celtics,
we got lucky in 2008 when uh,
when buying them was up,
you need a little bit of luck and the Lakers had it.
God Damn it.
And they want another one and you know,
they're up to fucking 16 championships.
The franchises and Laker fans can stand hand in hand with another man from
Minnesota and say we together have 16 or as in past.
And we can stand like men on our own and said,
we got 17 all right fuckers,
you fucking cunts.
Oh God,
I'm so pissed.
Jesus Christ.
This was really rushed to watch baseball.
I don't know why I tapped out from baseball.
I watch the Bruins lose four games in a row,
have to be an up three games to none.
And then I watched this lose a seven game fucking heartbreaker to the Goddamn
Lakers.
I was so hoping we were going to drink champagne.
Jesus Christ.
What were you fucking Laker fans do?
If you lost,
burned down the staples center,
you have to go back to the fucking forum.
That would actually be better.
I like to form better.
If you guys ever been to the form,
he got to go out there.
It's legendary,
legendary.
You come in there,
you can,
you just can see the old showtime Lakers.
You know,
you can see all the whores lining up waiting to fuck magic.
He used to get head right on the bench.
It's back when the NBA was great and they'd let you play.
And the fucking players,
we get blown right on the bench.
There was no WNB NBA.
Those bitches were on their knees blow in the star players in the NBA,
check it out.
It's all up on youtube if you don't believe me.
So,
uh,
so I got a couple of predictions I ever,
um,
the same way,
uh,
how the steroid case,
um,
started off small and became,
I think that the NBA has a major problem with their fucking officiating.
All right?
And once again,
I'm not making excuses.
I gave it up to the Lakers.
You're younger and you're more talented,
you deserve that.
You clamped down on defense.
Okay,
we good?
Can I make this point?
There's something going on.
I don't know what,
I'm not on the inside,
but remember I said that there is something going on with those officials there
either.
You know,
they had that one guy who got busted for having mob ties and somebody claims
somebody at the Improv last night was trying to tell me and I obviously I can't
back this up like most of my shit,
but they were trying to claim that some gamblers have been calling this guy in
prison,
Carl and phoning this guy and they'd been asking for gambling tips and he's
pretty much dead on.
If you tell them who's playing in what the officiating crew is,
he can't pick against the spread,
but he can tell you who the fuck is going to win.
Um,
just because he knows the personal vendettas they have and you know,
and if you look at Rashid has been a dick for years.
The refs fucking hate him.
That's why when he's standing flat footed sideways and Colby jumps into them,
it's an offense as a defensive foul.
So,
and I get it.
It's hard to set your personal shit aside,
but it was game seven.
You fucking Asshole,
you know?
But anyway,
I don't know.
I think,
uh,
I think it's a little fixed,
but it can't be fixed because the Lakers didn't even cover,
I don't know what's going on,
but there's something weird going on.
There's a deal at the very least to some new officiating style.
I think the reps might be finally just fed up with the fact that they only make
150 grand to fucking run up and down a basketball court,
which to Uri as a great job.
But I think they're sick of getting cursed out by 22 year old tattooed
millionaires.
I think they're tired of it.
And they've decided that,
um,
I don't know what they decided something,
but I don't know.
You don't have something,
I don't watch NBA hoop enough nowadays to,
to,
to really be 100% about that.
But any,
any hoop fans out there?
Can you,
can you go with me?
That doesn't seem like there's something weird going on
that it's the,
the,
it's like even when you watch baseball,
if somebody has a fucked up strike zone,
it's a consistent strikes on for the most part.
Okay.
He's,
he's,
he's calling that low on a strike tonight and for nine innings.
That's what the fucking guy does and as much as it pisses you off your first at
bat,
now you kind of know the guy's parameters.
But like with the officiating,
it's like they,
they're letting it go.
Then they're calling everything and it starting to make me feel like,
because it is a business,
then if one team goes,
goes up by too many points,
the officials kind of do shit to make sure that stays close so they get that
advertising money.
I Dunno.
Am I just pissed because my team lost.
I was saying that shit before when I went to that game when Garnette blew his
knee out and fucking a Utah that it seemed like something weird was going on.
Who knows?
We'll see what I think next week when I've maybe started to get over this
fucking loss.
You know,
it's the worst is when you,
when your team's shits the bed,
like the Bruin stared or if your team
loses a seven game heartbreaker to your absolute archrival.
The hardest thing is like you can't watch TV.
You can't watch any sports TV.
Campbell,
I've been watching like the food network.
I was actually watching a show the other day on a,
on this HD channel that has all this shit with like a bunch of cars and stuff
like psycho indycars,
my OCD.
Um,
I've gotten totally into cars and uh,
so I keep going to this channel and they actually had this unbelievable show.
It was basically about the bird and magics of like marine corps in army snipers
throughout the history of the US military.
They had the Michael Jordans of snipers and they had this dude,
man,
it was fucking,
it was the most fascinating God damn show
I've seen in a long time.
And I stumbled on it because I didn't want to watch the sports center,
you know,
the sports and watch sports center and listen to me or you're Celtics didn't get
it done.
You know,
they use,
you know those things to do and no you didn't do it.
They didn't go to,
I can't fucking watch that shit.
I know.
I got it.
They lost.
Um,
and I also didn't want to watch Colby jump up in the score table and do his one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
five rings.
But he really should be doing is counting how many fucking points he had that
weren't from the foul line.
Sorry,
had to get one more in.
Um,
so they showed this dude,
like I remember that big battle in Fallujah,
I guess it was in 2004 if he could fucking believe it was already like six years
ago.
And there was this marine corps sniper who had like 32 kills in 30 days and they
were talking about this guy was like shooting through like a softball size hall
at targets that were like four or 500 yards away.
And it's something,
again,
accuracy up to 600 yards,
six fucking football fields.
All right,
and you're peeking out from behind the rubble.
I think it's okay.
And then
you're fucking the back.
It gets blown out.
And they were talking about what a psychological mind fuck that was.
And then there are also,
they try to find you,
but they can't peek their heads out because this guy was so fucking bad ass.
Like Rick Barry from the foul line.
He's picking these dudes off and then he picked the dude's off,
would try to drag the dead dude out of the street just like in saving private
Ryan,
but reverse cause it was an American guy doing it.
And uh,
it was,
it was absolutely fascinating.
Then they went to,
after they were talking about that guy,
he has to sit there.
And those guys,
what they do on the other side is they just start lobbing like,
uh,
what does that mortar plus,
you know,
they stick it in that tube.
It goes boom.
You know,
it shoots over a couple of condos and he goes,
you just got to sit there and hope one doesn't have your name on it.
You know,
why do I watch action movies where there's actors who pretend to be bad ass when
you can watch shit like that.
That it was,
it was one of the fucking Manlius things I've ever seen in my life.
This guy was just picking people off.
He has to take into consideration cross winds,
how quickly these guys are running.
He was going after the guys like these,
it was like a video game.
Like the RPG guys were like worth like 2000 points.
You know,
if you just got some guy running across the street trying to get a fucking
Tabouli salad that was worth like 25.
Anyways.
So then after they got done talking to talking about that guy,
they talked about the,
they cut to this dude in,
um,
in Vietnam who had like 93 confirmed kills.
And uh,
he went head to head with some other badass sniper,
uh,
who was on the Vietcong and the Vietcong guy spotted them.
This,
how bad ass the Vietcong guy was.
He shot around by his foot as a challenge.
You know,
this guy was bored with picking off regular people,
so he wanted to go mano a mano with this other sniper and for like four days,
they're tracking each other through the,
through the jungle,
you know,
coming up on each other's flank,
whatever the fuck that means.
One dude would be like 300 yards in front of the other dude and then they be
crawling on their fucking elbows and somehow by the time they were done,
he'd be where that dude was.
And then the other dude was with the other dude was and just one day the via con
guy got unlucky
and it was the afternoon sun in it.
It glinted off his fucking whatever that what is there.
This is his gun scope in this guy literally did the shot from saving private
private Ryan.
He,
he shot at through the guys' scope and blew out the back of his fucking head and
the guy had a southern accent talking about,
went where I threw the scope,
didn't even touch the sides.
It was great.
He was like,
he was talking about some fishy cut,
eh,
Yay Shit Buddy.
I was down.
I got a fucking fish on dry land,
mother fucker top that one bitch.
He was doing that.
But talking about killing guys,
I don't know.
I have,
I wish I knew the name of the show,
but I found it absolutely fascinating.
One of those shows that so manly that you get,
you almost get insecure watching that you have to somehow start that you're the
guy in it,
you know,
and you start talking shit like you're the guy getting interviewed and you're
whispering to yourself on the couch and then you catch yourself going,
Jesus Christ.
Am I fucking crazy?
You know,
for the record I was getting interviewed on Oprah.
Is it any wonder why I'm in this business?
All right,
it is hot as hell in here.
They've got to keep the windows closed.
You know,
when you say content,
we fucking three seconds.
I get to keep the windows closed.
Um,
all right,
let's,
uh,
let's get to some of the shit here on the podcast.
Oh,
I wanted to,
I forgot to mention that I was gonna,
I was on Joe Rogan's podcast.
Um,
had a great time.
I went out to,
uh,
his bungalow and a,
I did his podcast two and a half hour podcast that went by in like three
seconds.
Um,
and for the life of me,
I don't know where the hell did tell you to go get it.
Just look up Joe Rogan podcast.
He's like hardcore into the Internet and technology and I'm sure his website
will take you by the hand and lead you right to his podcast.
So please check that out.
And uh,
one of the things we talked about on a Rogan's podcast was he was absolutely
beside himself that I was not on Twitter yet.
Um,
oh first that I didn't have a what does that thing you have in your car when you
don't want to look at a map anymore?
Keep saying,
Gee,
cast g map.
I map map 2.0 fucking do it for me.
I don't want to think anymore.
Um,
mapquest.
Fuck,
what is it called?
Whatever.
I don't have that thing.
I just said,
I have a map.
Can you tell me where you live?
And I look it up and then I,
I,
I get there.
There is no problem,
but for some reason people are blown away by that.
But it was even more blown away with by the fact that I,
I wasn't on Twitter.
So he actually signed me up for a Twitter account and I told them I don't do
that shit.
And he goes,
uh,
he kept saying,
you gotta do what you gotta do it.
It's the best way to hype you gigs.
So I'm asking you guys,
should I get on Twitter cause I don't wanna go into that on there and tweet
about some fucking cheeseburger.
I just had,
um,
I could,
like most people do,
but a Rogan was swearing up and down.
This is that this is the best way to do it.
Like,
he was like,
you don't even need to do radio.
He just get a bunch of followers on Twitter and you tell them where you're going
to be and then they can all go out and see you.
Like that fucking Korean barbecue truck that drives around here out in La.
People are on Twitter to see his fucking truck that has insane Korean barbecue.
And people are like,
you know,
follow the thing on Twitter.
And they're like,
Hey,
I'm on so and such and such and vine and everybody drives over to go get some
fucking Korean barbecue.
So,
um,
anyways,
we have a poll on the MM podcast.com if you guys,
you know,
if you'd like it,
if you want me to be on Twitter,
uh,
I'll do it.
But I gotta be honest with you.
I'm not going to be,
uh,
I'll only be tweeting,
you know,
I'll tweet like I just put the podcast just is,
uh,
just got posted.
I can't even,
I can't do Twitter tweet.
That's fucking ridiculous.
You know what it is?
This part of me though,
I got to stop fighting this shit.
You know,
by the time I got onto Facebook it was fucking irrelevant.
Nobody gives a shit.
Now everybody's on Twitter,
you know I'm giving in a little bit.
I'm compromising.
Fuck it.
What do you want me to do?
Huh?
You want me to be the spokesperson for BP?
I'll do it.
Shit.
You don't stop that.
I could do a better fucking jobs in their spokespersons are doing,
what's their latest spokesperson?
What?
What the fuck is that guy saying?
They're only birds.
I've got to open the window here.
Sorry,
Cleo.
Sorry.
She gets so fucking freaked out whenever I do that.
Then she starts shaking uncontrollably.
Sorry.
All right,
let's get back to the podcast,
so let me know.
It's his Twitter is stupid as I think it is or is it actually decent,
but I'm going to be honest with you.
If you say to get on Twitter,
I'm not going to be tweeting,
just got an ice cream and the host scoop fell in my laugh.
O G lol.
I'm not fucking doing that.
All right,
I'll,
I'll have the most boring tweets.
But then that's the thing,
you get on there and then you gotta,
you gotta try to be fucking interesting.
Oh,
gives a fuck.
Go,
go on the [inaudible] podcast.
Let me know what you think,
you know,
and maybe send me some emails and let me know some of the positive things.
Even thinking if you really think it sucks,
just let me know.
All right,
so there you go.
45 minutes in.
Let's get to some of the questions here.
Um,
oh,
somebody send me,
here's another tech question for you.
As somebody sent me something about a saying,
hey bill,
I don't have an iPhone.
Can,
uh,
you know,
can you make it easier for me to listen to the thing at work?
I don't want to have to be,
you know,
I guess I don't know what,
listen to it on the computer.
So I,
I emailed the guy back like,
well,
can't you listen to it on your iPod?
It seemed like he had one of those jobs where he,
I forget what his job was,
but it was like he went to job sites.
Um,
I dunno,
is there another place where I can post the Monday morning podcast for people to
listen to it on their phones?
I mean,
I dunno,
I have no idea.
But,
uh,
he seemed to be the only guy who said some shit like that,
but just in case it was a problem.
Um,
if you guys have like tech savvy fucking questions,
I don't know what to do about it,
but if you can point me in a direction that will make it easier for you to
listen to this thing,
I'll try to do it as long as it doesn't involve,
you know,
900 bucks in like three weeks worth of work here.
Um,
all right.
And also I added a couple of Boston dates I've got to put up on my,
uh,
website.
One is up in New Hampshire for the life of me.
It's Sunday,
so I don't know where the fuck it is.
I gotta talk to my agent tomorrow,
but the other one is on August 12th.
I'm going to be in,
um,
the 2010 new port summer comedy series at the new New Port Yachting Center.
Huh?
You like that moving up in the world?
Um,
yeah.
it's a seven 30 show August 12th that by the time you listen to this,
I'll at least have that,
post that up on my website and I know the day before or the day after,
I'm going to be up in New Hampshire.
So all you people up in Maine,
you know,
you people over in Connecticut,
you know there's a couple of gigs that are easier to drive to.
Hang on a second.
All right,
here we go.
Um,
youtube videos for the week.
here's one that I think is really funny,
but also I can't tell if it's fake or not.
Please let me know.
It's called BMW chase and it's a couple of rednecks judging to people in this
little BMW car.
They chase after him and for some reason they're filming it.
And um,
you think the guy in the BMW is going to get his ass kicked and all of a sudden
the tables turn.
It's a,
it's pretty interesting,
but I don't know if it's real or not.
Um,
and also the 21 foot rule over that last week,
uh,
the guy put up one more,
he did a final video where he actually hurts himself.
Evidently
this guy is out of his mind.
And if I worked for the FBI,
I would definitely be watching this guy at all.
Fucking times.
21 foot rule,
final video,
go to the Mlm,
podcast.com.
All right,
just go there.
We'll have all of these up here.
And if you're a dog lover,
please do not watch this one.
All right,
dear versus dog.
Um,
to long story,
there's a baby deer and then the mother dear comes in or it looks like an
adolescent dear to make sure the baby deers.
Okay.
And there's a cat that gets a knocked around a little bit,
but the dog gets absolutely pummeled.
The dog gets pummeled
and it's,
it was really uncomfortable to watch.
But uh,
for some reason I'm talented and I'm laughing.
I don't know why cause it wasn't funny.
So if you,
I don't know,
if you don't like watching a dog get pummeled by a deer,
check it out.
But for you future serial killers who have already begun torturing animals,
there's a video for you.
All right?
Underrated.
Overrated for the week.
Um,
this is a great one.
Underrated.
Letting your frozen pizza cool for the recommended two minutes after pulling it
out of the oven.
Good Lord.
That's such a classic drunk food or like you're just absolutely starving and
you've just fired in the microwave or the oven and the second it's done,
you just fucking,
you do a couple of,
and then you bite into it and then you got to do that.
You gotta like a,
you're like fanning your mouth as if that's ever worked.
And then for the next four days,
because you didn't,
you didn't wait two minutes.
You have that white burned flesh,
the top of your mouth.
I have somehow dislocated my jaw.
The fuck is going on here.
Went to the dentist and they gave me a fucking mouth guard because I grind my
teeth at night cause I'm a psycho.
Oh fucking Kalia.
[inaudible].
Evidently I do that at night.
So I got this mouth guard and now all of a sudden my job pops in and out and he
fucking dentists out there.
I gave you a big shout out last week by let you know that I know both canines as
six and 11,
eight,
nine or downtown,
right?
MMM.
Yeah.
If you know how to fucking do that every once in awhile pops up.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
plowing ahead here.
A overrated,
those membership cars.
This guy obviously is a new listener,
so I think I'm up to 15 listeners here.
Uh,
overrated.
Listen to this.
This is unsolicited by me.
This guy's obviously a new listener because sir,
if you're listening to this,
uh,
I have done numerous podcasts about these things and I also have a bit about it
coming in.
My upcoming special,
yeah.
Coming out in September,
uh,
overrate he said those membership cards with all the,
that all the fucking chain stores in night now trying to push on you.
Apparently if I give them my name,
email address and a record of my shopping habit habits,
I could be saving hundreds of dollars a year.
Really?
I'm supposed to believe a giant soulless corporation wants to help me out.
Sure.
I may save a buck or two,
but when I buy a seat when I buy a CD,
but at what cost?
At what fucking costs.
Exactly,
sir.
Congratulations.
You're a thinking human being.
These other people are just like,
oh,
they're trying to help you out.
They want you to save money while they make less money,
despite the fact that you would go to the store anyways,
they're morons.
And here's a recommended video.
A movie.
Actually,
I didn't check this out,
but this sounds like a great psycho movie.
I talked a little bit here.
I talked about snipers.
I T I made a reference to serial killers,
so I think this is a fine way to end the podcast here by wrecking.
I'm recommending a movie called rampage.
At least find out more about it.
I guess it's a small independent film,
but it says,
a dejected by the futility of is tedious life.
A bitter small town resident takes matters into his own hands by constructing a
bulletproof outfit,
uh,
picking up his semiautomatic weapons and attempting the largest killing spree
killing spree ever seen,
written and directed by a controversial film maker.
Who we ball,
I don't know you.
W E.
B o,
l.
L is that [inaudible] ball.
If you ball this ultra violent action movie feature features,
jarring,
handheld camera work and original dialogue,
largely improvised by the cast.
How you watch that movie
is beyond me.
I would love to hear that improvised dialogue.
Oh,
don't shoot.
I mean,
what else would you fuck it?
Say acting like it's fucking,
uh,
Larry,
what's his face?
Uh,
Larry.
David.
I'm so bad with the fucking names.
Uh,
anyways,
that's the podcast this week.
It's a little short.
This week I got a mid,
I'm a little fucking burned out.
I did a podcast.
I did my podcast,
Adam Carolla's podcast and I did,
um,
Joe Rogan's podcast.
I did,
I'm literally making an unpaid career
out of these podcasts,
but they're there just to fucking there to,
I forgot to say I did Adam Carolla's podcast to um,
check his out is his,
actually,
he actually,
he's one of those guys who actually has 2 million fucking listeners and
advertisers.
His podcast is everything that I want this thing to be at some point,
but I'm just too fucking lazy to go out there.
You know what?
I would love to have a bunch of,
of,
of advertisement on this podcast,
but it's of Shit that I enjoy,
you know,
like my respect for snipers.
Like if somebody wanted to advertise their sniper scope,
are you sick and your neighbor?
Do you want to scare the shit out of him?
Or maybe take out a house pet chick out the fucking ask Sam 3000 millimeter
fucking guns scope.
Even a fucking mutant could kill someone a 300 fucking yards through a picket
fucking fats,
some shit like that.
Maybe we'll have that.
Maybe we'll try out advertising on this.
Don't do free advertising for random shit.
You know,
Shit that I actually fucking use like toilets.
You Shit that you sick of Shit shitting outside.
Once you get a toilet,
you dumb.
Fuck,
it's 2010.
Oh that guy.
Everybody if there are more on,
has to have a southern accent.
I've addressed that in my act.
What else would,
what else,
whether kind of advertising,
Belvedere,
vodka,
limes,
if you make limes,
you grow limes,
I should say.
What else?
That's about it.
Vodka,
gun scopes and toilets.
Let's start there.
That'll be the,
uh,
the advertising.
You know,
that reminds me a long time ago,
um,
when guns and roses there,
their appetite for destruction came out.
They had that song called night train and the people of a,
I guess it's some sort of cheap booze.
I don't know if it's wine.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
Um,
but the people at nitrane one slash to be a spokesperson and do this is back in
the day where if you were a spokesperson for something,
like you lost like 30% of your audience,
you were considered a sellout.
Nowadays,
these fucking Lady Gaga guys can be fucking,
have their legs spread around.
Some of Y'all play yogurt,
make an extra fucking money.
Nobody gives a shit.
But back in the day,
that was a big thing,
but he actually would have got away with it because it would have been so funny
because their whole thing was that were were alcoholics.
Um,
but at the last second,
uh,
some groups complained,
um,
that it would actually,
what would that do to the youth?
What would that encourage them to do?
And that's one of the Times,
few times that they were actually 100% right.
Because if,
if slash yeah,
in 1988,
89 told me to drink night train,
I would have,
I would've would've been hilarious.
We would have drank night nitrane while we listened to night train and out and
are safe suburbs.
We would have thought we were bad ass on some level.
All right.
I think that's it.
That was a little little fucker reminiscing.
I took you back to 1988 you know when the first George Bush was in office,
you know when he had some sort of restraint sort of stick and move in the Middle
East.
Just fucking blast him right in the face and then leave.
Let them think about it.
Don't let them fly around the country.
Um,
anyways,
let me hide my guest for this week.
I am beyond excited.
I'm going to be in Las Vegas this weekend.
Co headlining with a comedian and television star.
Tom Papa.
Okay.
The host and star of the marriage.
Ref on NBC.
Please watch the show.
Tom Papa,
good friend of my podcast and I'll be advertising.
Tom,
I don't,
I'm advertising Tom pop right now and we co headlining with him at the Orleans
Casino in Las Vegas a Friday and Saturday night this weekend.
Uh,
what the fuck dates of those?
Hang on,
hang on.
Don't get your panties in.
An uproar.
A,
that would be the 25th and the 26th of June.
C'Mon out all you people in Vegas but asked me to come out there.
I finally got a finally got a gig out there and,
and as a comedian,
it's an honor to perform there.
That's the last place I guess George Carlin did stand up.
So,
uh,
I'm going to try to talk to a security and see if maybe I can not take a peek at
the theater,
maybe make a quick little video.
I always promise videos and then I never ended up doing them.
But maybe I can make a quick little video of me working in Vegas.
Yeah.
Uh,
actually a cool Vegas Vegas video where I'm not out there acting like strip
clubs are fun
rather than their,
if they're fucking okay
debt's overrated titty bars.
Titty bars are overrated unless you're under the age of 23,
you fucking,
you know,
23 are under strict.
Did a titty bars are great.
Well,
you get a little bit older than that.
It's fucking horrific.
You just wasted money in and makes you fucking hate women.
Um,
and I think actually the strippers,
they start to hate guys after a while,
but I think that they would like guys a lot more if they were fucking wide eyed.
2021,
two year olds.
Oh boy.
Look at the vagina.
I gave her a dollar and she showed me her titty.
So polio ploy
to this is the greatest night ever when you're still in that phase.
And I'm not making fun of 22,
23 years old,
old.
Cause I wasn't that,
that I,
you know,
I was that guy at that age and I'm sure a bunch you will email me now and
telling me how fucking bad ass Yara and all the pussy you're getting.
You know,
I don't give a fuck.
Okay.
I was your age.
I actually was I getting any at that age.
I had a bad,
I was a late fucking bloomer,
you know,
you know the middle period where mark McGwire uh,
right before he started doing steroids,
when he fucking tapered off.
That was like my pussy getting career in my early twenties.
And then I moved to New York and uh,
it all worked itself out.
Yeah.
If he can't get laid and moved to New York,
by the way,
it's,
it's just,
it's fucking impossible not to eat this.
They're just walking down the street.
I was back there last weekend.
I forgot about that.
Like when you're driving around
La,
they're in cars.
You can't get to them.
They're boxed in.
But in New York you can just harass the shit out of them.
It's like the host cities,
just a big construction site,
eh,
sweet tits.
Oh,
come.
You're going to be like that.
It's a matter.
I just made you uncomfortable.
I just threw out a,
maybe you're going to get raped,
vibe.
I can't believe you fucking giving me this attitude.
No,
I was never that guy.
But I actually,
I used to always meet girls in the gym and oddly enough,
I actually met a couple on the subway.
I think because they have their guard up not to get mugged,
but they don't think that you're going to start hitting on him.
And what I would usually do,
I think I told this story,
I would wait for somebody to do something weird or fucking stupid,
which happens all the time on the subway.
And if they would react to it by laughing a little bit,
then you went in and I had to do was make a joke and then I was in,
you know,
and hopefully if they had,
if I got,
you know,
I try to just get their number,
but if I got desperate I would whore out the fact that I was a comedian.
Actually,
I'm a comedian,
I'll be down in the comedy cellar tonight,
which is such a bitch move.
But I did it all the time.
Shamelessly can a business card with me fucking holding a microphone.
So they knew I was a comedian.
You know,
the fuck I did what I had to do.
Look at me.
I look like Richie Cunningham.
What do you want from me?
Look at,
I'm over an hour again.
Just like that.
That's how it goes.
All right,
so that is,
oh,
a new episode of uninformed by taped with,
uh,
Joe de Rosa.
The new young teen sensation of the OPN Anthony show.
Oh,
I want to thank those guys,
by the way,
last week for having me go on and height my show.
And I want to thank [inaudible] guys,
Kevin,
and being out here in La and Adam Carolla.
Phil,
let me a height.
My shows out here in Los Angeles,
all the shows sold out and,
uh,
makes you feel good.
So that's it.
Hope you guys have a great week and let me know.
You want me to do the tweak thing on Twitter?
Um,
I know I'm really copping out here.
I'm acting like Julius Caesar.
Do you want me to kill the son of God?
I mean,
it's up to you.
I'll do whatever you want me to do.
Uh,
but go the,
uh,
the man podcast.com.
Check out all the videos and all that type of stuff.
And
do you have a good week?
I'm going to start watching the world's cup.
All right.
That's it.
[inaudible].